[Music]  Kylie Jenner celebrates boyfriend Travis  Scott's birthday in the most epic way  know when Kylie just rents out Six Flags  for the night the 20 year old reality  stars beau turns 26 on Monday and Kylie  made sure he had a birthday to remember  by renting out the entire amusement park  Kylie's sisters Kourtney Kim and Kendall  all came out for the fun night of  rollercoaster riding I'm not going on  Superman but I will go on the Riddler  right here even Kanye made an appearance  rocking an all neon ensemble but the  highlight of the festivities was  definitely Travis's custom-made birthday  cake featuring figurines of him and  Kylie on a roller coaster with their two  month old daughter stormy sitting on  Kylie's lap I said I told them I said  make sure you store me as a seatbelt  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]